we're asked to convert these linear
equations into slope intercept form
slope intercept form and then graph them
on a single coordinate plane we have our
coordinate plane over here and just as a
bit of review slope intercept form is
the form y is equal to
m x plus b where m is the slope and b is
the intercept that's why it's called
slope intercept form so we just have to
algebraically manipulate these equations
into this form so let's start with line
a so let's start with line a
so line a it's in standard form right
now it's 4x
plus 2y
is equal to negative 8. the first thing
i'd like to do is get rid of this
negative get rid of this 4x from the
left hand side and the best way to do
that is to subtract 4x from both sides
of this equation
so let me subtract 4x from both sides
the left-hand side of the equation these
two four x's cancel out and i'm just
left with two y
is equal to
and on the right-hand side i have
negative four x minus eight
negative four x minus eight or eight
minus or negative eight minus 4x however
you want to view it
now we're almost at slope-intercept form
we just have to get rid of this 2 and
the best way to do that that i can think
of is divide both sides of this equation
by 2.
so let's divide both sides by 2. so we
divide the left hand side by 2 and then
divide the right hand side by 2. you
have to divide every term by 2 and then
we are left with
y
y is equal to negative 4 divided by 2 is
negative 2x
negative 8 divided by 2 is
negative 4. negative 2x minus 4. so this
is
our this is line a and let me graph it
right now so line a its y-intercept is
negative four so the point zero negative
four is on this graph if x is equal to
zero y is going to be equal to negative
four you can just substitute that in the
graph so zero one two three four that's
the point
0 negative 4
that's the y-intercept for line a
and then the slope
the slope is negative 2x so that means
that if i change x by positive 1 that y
goes down by negative 2. so let's do
that so if i go over 1 in the positive
direction i have to go down 2. that's
what a negative slope is going to do
negative 2 slope if i go over 2 i'm
going to have to go down 4.
if i go back negative 1 so if i if i
go in the x direction negative 1 that
means in the y direction i go positive 2
because 2 divided by negative 1 is still
negative 2. so i go over here if i go
back 2 i'm going to go up 4.
let me just do that a couple of back 2
and then up 4. so this line is going to
look like this
this line is going to look like this do
my best to draw it
that's a decent job that is line a right
there all right let's do line b
line b
so line b
they say 4x 4x is equal to negative 8
and you might be saying hey how do i get
that into slope intercept form i don't
see y and the answer is you won't be
able to because this can't be put into
slope intercept form but we can simplify
it so let's divide both sides of this
equation by 4
so you divide both sides of this
equation by 4 and you get x is equal to
negative 2. so this just means i don't
care what your y is x is just always
going to be equal to negative 2. so x is
equal to negative 2 is right there
negative 1 negative 2 and x is just
always going to be equal to negative 2.
x is always going to be equal to
negative 2
in both directions and this is a bit of
view this is the x-axis that's the
y-axis i forgot to label them now let's
do this last character 2y is equal to
negative 8.
so line c
we have 2y is equal to negative 8. we
can divide both sides of this equation
by 2
divide both sides of this equation by 2
and we get y
is equal to negative 4. so you might say
hey sal that doesn't look like this form
slope intercept form but it is it's just
that the slope is zero we could rewrite
this as y is equal to zero x minus four
where the y-intercept is negative four
and the slope is zero
y-intercept is negative 4
y-intercept is negative 4 right there
and the slope is 0. so if you move an
arbitrary amount in the x-direction the
y is not going to change it's just going
to stay at negative 4. let me do that a
little bit neater
y is just going to stay at negative 4.
or you can just interpret is y is equal
to negative 4 no matter what x is
so then we are done